السيد مصطفى انتم كيف تنظرون الى هذه
الزيارات ورمزياتها عشيه الانتخابات خاصه
بان اسطنبول لم تمنح اصواتها وان كان
بفارق ضئيل ولكن لم تفتح اصواتها للرئيس
اردوغان في الجوله الاولى كيف ترون هذه
الزيارات والرسائل منها للناخب التركي
والناخب في اسطنبول تحديدا
نحن نعلم بان الرئيس اردوغان هو ينتهج
سلسله سياسات قيميه
نعلم بان اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه
كان
طبعا يركز بذلك ومن قبل الجيش وكذلك
المجال الديني كان مبعدين عن السياسه فيما
مضى ولكن راينا انه في فتره حكمه اردوغان
نجد انه قد ادخل هما المجالين او ادخل
السياسه في هذين المجالين بقوه
وصحيح ونحن لا ننكر وجود هذه القيم اهتمام
ولكن تركيا نعم بلد مسلم وتركيا كذلك ان
كانت ربما
احيانا
تجد بعض ربما بتناقضات فيما مضى ولكن نحن
يجب ان لا
نعلم ايضا بان
المساجد وكذلك الجيش يجب ان لا تكون ضمن
التعاطيء انا شخصيا ربما لست منزعج كمواطن
عن قيام الرئيس بهذه الزيارات فهو امر
طبيعي ولكن جعل هذه المسائل وسيله للسياسه
واستغلالها السياسيين اعتقد انه تصرف خاطئ
انا اقول الرئيس اردوغان هو
ينتهج سياسه قيم ولكن بشكل عشوائي ودون
اتزان وميزان